what's happened to reject nation it's
Greg out here and it's John over in here
so Warner Brothers kava-kava battles
going on they just released the trailer
for ready player 1s Evansville Varig oh
yeah Steven Spielberg finally back in
the sci-fi genre people talk in my movie
talk boys a lot of people say Akira in
relation to this I'm very curious as to
what that looks like
I live here in Columbus Ohio and 20:45
it still ranked the fastest-growing city
on earth
but it sure doesn't seem like it when
you live in fact they called our
generation the missing millions missing
missing not because we went anywhere
there's nowhere left to go nowhere
except the Oasis
the only place that feels you can answer
all my questions perfectly the reality
of your own imagination Wow
[Music]
Wow tell ya higher charge
[Music]
oh boy
oh wow
[Music]
Oh recruiter
well now I am
[Applause]
was crazy
oh my gosh bill Bert holiday oh yeah
there's a slice of Texas back to the
future
this guy's imagination is only the
movies you see this seems like a much
much better version of pixels all the
King dude yeah in that Easter Egg man I
haven't read the book but from what I
know about it this guy way to find the
key one of the keys to this Easter Egg
that's hidden inside the game that's
linked to some kind of fortune of the
game creator oh yeah if they're
following the book and the writer of the
book co-wrote the movie I mean that
looks awesome to me because it's been a
while since Spielberg has really dove
into sci-fi
and he looks like he's going all out
heavys I have a heavy
science fiction we're dealing with here
the idea of it like an MMO of virtual
reality where your imagination is kind
of creating it all together at the same
time seeing the homage to like other
movies Back to the Future Iron Giant
what my friend cruiser was in there at
one point that's really cool I mean I've
always wanted to see a movie that does
that but it also looks like intense
action-packed the visual looks stunning
we don't really know the main character
that well yet but this was just an
introduction to the world of what we can
see yeah I mean this is all the cool
stuff I feel like like s trailer was all
wow
eckel you know and now just moving
forward I hope the next one gives me a
better sense what the real story will be
like yeah because it's been a hot minute
since he's done some type of blockbuster
film it's funny to me that this whole
thing is about essentially a videogame
this looks like a game trailer like I
know I was wanting a video game trailer
like something out of a three I almost
feel like this was an ad for Oasis and
not as much for ready player one the
movies just because like I'm aside from
that first part you get in the city
stack you don't get much of a sense for
the real world and I get the sense the
real world is mess
up in this movie ravaged by global
warming so we're going to get two types
of worlds we're going to get the real
world then we're going to get the
virtual reality world I can imagine the
contrast is going to have to be some
kind of you know at least a plot points
guy has no sexual thoughts instead of
his virtual reality room no it's I mean
it's all science fiction I see now what
hot woman running around any other time
it doesn't play there alright guys well
do you like the ready player one trailer
the Scott Summers of students over I
gotta know if you like the ready later
one trailer it's got some subscribe to
the reel rejects click that notification
bell he is that John Humphrey on Twitter
and Instagram social media manager of
Blum house comm and as always you can
check out our exclusive perks and
rewards over at patreon.com slash the
real rejects where you can help
contribute to a game rid of those people
who ride motorcycles right outside our
window Oh Steven summers directed The
Mummy with Brendan Fraser's got summers
of cycles yeah Steven summers directed
of The Mummy with Brendan Fraser